in the mid 17th century
the small country of holland was a
crowning testament
to the empire of mankind
[Music]
its science art trade and military
prowess reaching never before seen
heights
during this golden age
[Music]
the dutch enjoyed wealth and power not
just across europe
but the widening world as a whole
in the small city of delft a wealthy
draper and chamberlain takes the scenic
route
home from his office enjoying the final
glow of the late afternoon sun
he walks along the canals glimpsing tiny
fish and wriggling things
darting between the lengthening shadows
above his head towering lime trees are
filled with birdsong
as these delicate creatures dart from
branch to branch
occasionally one may drop to the ground
to search among the
wilting tulips for a worm or grub
the city is filled with life the trees
flowers birds fish and insects
are pleasant gilded trimmings to the
rich fabric
of delft society
but the draper doesn't linger on the
canal sides
he is eager to return home and to his
true
passion his lenses
for this draper is anthony van
leeuwenhoek
and while his days are filled with bolts
of cloth and sheaves of paperwork
his knights are his own
[Music]
he fills them with perfectly curved
shards of glass
that allow him to peer into another
world
a tiny lens of lavenhauk's own making is
sandwiched between plates of brass
he holds it up to his eye bringing his
face close to a droplet of water
dispensed from a vial full retrieved
from the canals that very afternoon
he is fascinated and mystified by what
he sees
intricate creatures tiny specks busying
themselves about their minute
droplet world
they are as industrious and
self-absorbed as delft's own residents
but this is a watery city writ small
leeuwenhoek names these microscopic
inhabitants
animal cults and his is probably the
first human eye
to knowingly witness them
in the years that follow he will
document and illustrate single-celled
creatures we now know
as protozoa and then later
even smaller living things that we know
as
bacteria
he will take samples from ponds puddles
and wells and from the human mouth and
intestine
and everywhere he looks with the help of
precious lenses
he will find life
leeuwenhoek was one of the first people
in the world to see
the microcosmos to realize its ubiquity
and its staggering diversity
[Music]
today some 350 years later we know that
microscopic life is all around us
even though it remains invisible to the
unaided eye
bacteria and microorganisms are on our
bodies and inside them
helping us harming us or simply living
among us
they permeate almost every natural
environment
and have done since before the first
humans
even before the first full-sized animals
took center stage on the earth
the pretty little animals that swim
wriggle and flutter around dolph's
canals
may be attractive trimming to the fabric
of life but
humans for all their self-awareness and
civilization
are merely part of that trimming too
instead earth's microbes comprise the
warp and
weft of the biosphere and scientists are
still striving to understand
our place among them just how exactly
are we related to layman hoax animal
kills
how far back can we trace our origins
and what exactly
does the tapestry of life look like
the answers lie hidden in the vast sheen
of life that coats our world
and every living being within
it will take a grand tour of this
biosphere
to uncover those secrets
hello and welcome to the entire history
of the earth
as we approach the first anniversary of
the creation of this channel we'd like
to thank
you the viewer for joining us on this
most epic of journeys
and now also our very first sponsor a
longtime supporter of the history
brothers network
it's magellan tv here you can find more
than 3 000 documentaries on practically
any subject you can think
of all streamed seamlessly to whichever
device you choose
our recommendation this week is exotic
invaders
a fascinating exploration of what
happens when one animal invades a
different ecosystem
and this is just one example
and you can now take advantage of an
exclusive offer 30
off an annual membership this gives you
an entire year for less than 3.50 a
month even if you've joined magellan
before and lapsed
you can simply click on the link in the
description to claim your discounted
membership today
thanks
[Music]
in 1936 a seven-year-old boy sat fishing
in the meandering delta of the alabama
river
when an accidental flick and a tug
damaged and blinded
his right eye the child suffered for
hours but never complained
he knew that if the adults learned of
his predicament they would take him home
back to the city away from the glorious
countryside
because this was where young edward
loved to be
immersed in nature
it was worth the pain in his one eye so
that the other
could witness the wonders of the natural
world
[Music]
eventually surgery would give him his
sight back but it would never
be quite as it had once been with only
2010 vision he could no longer make out
the sweeping landscapes and large
animals that used to so fascinate him
but his love of nature was unshakable
and instead he turned his attention to
the smaller creatures
of the world his good eye
could pick out the hairs on the back of
an ant's body or the fine patterns on a
butterfly's wing
in fact this freak accident would help
shape the young boy's life
setting him on the path to becoming a
dedicated entomologist
and a lover of all living things both
great
and small
edward o wilson grew up to be a
world-renowned
naturalist author philosopher and today
the world's leading
authority on ants
these tiny unassuming insects drew
wilson's attention like no other
their diversity social organization and
sheer tenacity in almost every part of
the world is remarkable in itself
the ants are the most abundant insect on
earth
with more than 12 000 distinct species
and perhaps as many as a quadrillion
individuals that's enough to outnumber
us humans by about a million to one
although each ant weighs just four
milligrams the total mass of ants on the
planet is not
far off the total mass of humans just a
couple of hundred years ago
when our population was lower the ants
truly were
the heavyweights of the animal world
a few thousand years before that
dwarfing
humanity in scale
considering ourselves as lesser animals
in a world dominated by ants
may be a hard pill to swallow but even
these diverse
numerous and collectively weighty
creatures are but a minor part of
earth's biological bounty
understanding the true extent of earth's
biosphere is a herculean task
and one that scientists are still
grappling with today
[Music]
planetary science has given us the tools
to describe a planet in intricate detail
from its inner core to its outermost
boundary with space
the surface layers can be classified by
their composition
the rocky lithosphere makes up the solid
crust
the hydrosphere sees water cycled
between the oceans clouds and rivers
and the atmosphere is a 500 kilometer
thick gaseous blanket
that swaddles warms and protects
together the composition and relative
scale of these three components come to
define
any planet's surface conditions
but on earth at least there is another
component
permeating the solid lithosphere the
liquid hydrosphere and gaseous
atmosphere
is another sphere made of life itself
the biosphere
this living component of our planet
covers and penetrates the solid surface
of the land
it fills rivers lakes and oceans to the
deepest darkest depths
and even stretches many kilometers up
into the atmosphere
the biosphere is a global ecosystem made
up not just of living things
but also the non-living portions of our
planet that are inextricably linked to
life
just as the hydrosphere is a continuous
cycle of water between ice oceans and
clouds
so too is the biosphere a continuous
cycle
of life
the cycling of carbon nutrients and raw
energy through living things is what
keeps us
alive not only as individuals but as a
four billion year old ecosystem
and as a planet as a whole
the biosphere has been a critical
component of the earth since life first
arose in the early archean
that life had the same basic qualities
of life today
it could self-sustain and self-replicate
sensing moving and responding to
external stimuli
but in the intervening four billion
years or so the character of the
biosphere has changed drastically
from isolated communities of microscopic
cells in shallow pools and around deep
ocean vents
earth's life has gone from strength to
strength
the modern biosphere is host to a
staggering diversity of life forms
of seemingly limitless variety in shape
size
and lifestyle
[Music]
there are the humans of course leaving
our mark on the planet in the mighty
civilizations we build and the resources
we consume
but we are just one of many animals that
call
earth our home we are mammals
a group that includes the giant blue
whale the venomous stuck-billed platypus
alongside all manner of hoofed clawed
and even
winged furry creatures
but mammals belong to a larger group of
vertebrates
animals with a spine that also includes
the scaly reptiles
the feathered birds water-bound fish and
amphibians
that enjoy the best of the water and the
land
animals without spines the invertebrates
are just as diverse
and include the arthropods which
encompasses insects like the hugely
numerous ants
plus arachnids and hard shelled
crustaceans
mollusks may or may not have a hard
protective shell around their fleshy
body
they include creatures like clams snails
and the dextrous octopus
some invertebrates like corals and
sponges build themselves scaffolds from
inorganic materials
while other invertebrates embrace their
spinelessness to become fluid-like
creatures that rely on water
soil or sand around them to keep their
shape
they include a wide range of worms
jellyfish and strange
deep sea creatures that seem to evade
description
altogether
[Music]
the animal kingdom is breathtakingly
diverse it holds us in strange
fascination as we see
some form of our own consciousness
mirrored in even the most bizarre
tentacled body
[Music]
but in sheer numbers and diversity
animals are dwarfed by another form
[Music]
plants can trace their origins back to
the first photosynthesizing cell
in earth's early oceans
but like the animals they have
improvised and diversified beyond
all recognition today's biosphere is
home to towering redwoods
vast expanses of grassland lush
rainforests and their vertical
organization
and flowering plants specifically
tailored to their pollinators preference
there are plants adapted to every
possible habitat and lifestyle on land
from the highest peaks to the driest
deserts
they have evolved to survive drought
flood fire and barren cold
through their ubiquity and their
capacity for growth despite
the overwhelming population growth of
humanity in recent centuries
plants still make up more than 80
percent
of all the living mass on earth
of course animals and plants are joined
on the surface by yet another form of
life
perhaps the most mysterious of all with
roots hundreds of millions of years ago
fungi
if the inner machinations of plants are
difficult for us to understand then the
fungi
are even more of an enigma
mushrooms yeasts and molds exist as a
mythical network
that invisibly connects beneath the
surface the living world
[Music]
but for all their mystery we know them
to be a crucial component
of earth's biosphere
they are the key to the circle of life
recycling dead creatures back to their
component molecules
for use by life once more
this macroscopic living world has been
the subject of study and speculation for
thousands of years
but when anthony van leeuwenhoek first
peered through his lenses in the 17th
century
he opened a door to another hidden side
of earth's biosphere
the microscopic world
the denizens of this world may be tiny
but their collective might
is huge there are microscopic animals
like rotifers and tardigrades
but other creatures consisting of only
one cell cannot rightly be considered
animal plant or fungus
those single cells with a nucleus are
the protists
which include predatory amoeba as well
as multitudinous forms of
photosynthesizing
algae in shades of green brown and gold
seaweeds including the great kelp
forests of the world's coastlines
a little more than a loose collection of
these sun-loving
single cells
but even the protists are outnumbered by
an even
smaller even more numerous and
potentially more diverse group
the bacteria
these single cells lack a nucleus or
other cellular machinery
but that hasn't stopped them from
conquering the entire biosphere
just a thousandth of a millimeter across
these hardy prokaryotic cells
permeate every possible habitat on earth
they've been found deep beneath ice
sheets clustering around acidic
volcano pools and floating high in the
atmosphere
they are on and in our bodies in
astounding number
it is a commonly voiced myth that
bacterial cells outnumber our own body's
cells
some ten to one while modern scientists
have since revised that figure down
to roughly one to one each of us still
plays host
to 30 trillion other living things
[Music]
despite their miniscule size the sum
total of bacterial biomass
is some thousand times greater than that
of all humans on earth
as we go about our long lives learning
about the natural world and developing
the tools and technology with which to
understand it
it's easy for us human animals to
consider ourselves
masters of all
we undoubtedly have abilities no other
living things possess
but elsewhere within the biosphere other
life forms have skills and natural
talents of which we can only dream
[Music]
we cannot harvest and carry a hundred
times our own weight
like the industrious ants we cannot make
our own food from the raw
energy of the sun like plants we cannot
eke out in existence in caustic pools of
acid
like the hardiest prokaryote
[Music]
the diversity of earth's modern
biosphere is one of its greatest wonders
and we about minor players in its
spectacular chorus line
by every measure we humans are outgunned
and outnumbered
but at the same time we are part of this
vast
interconnected web of life able to trace
our origins back
some 4 billion years
and reconstructing the family tree of
earth's living world
can help us find our true place within
our planet's
unique biosphere
for centuries scholars have tried to
understand our place within the natural
world
in ancient greece aristotle was among
the first to speculate that animals
were superior to the plants because of
their ability to move
and to sense and react to the outside
world
classical teachings like these persisted
into the middle ages
when a more elaborate scheme of
classification was developed
that ranked all the matter in life that
we were aware of as part of a great
chain of being
at the pinnacle of this great chain was
of course god
the creator of all followed closely
behind by the angels
and then man
beneath mankind came the animals with
kingly animals like lions ranking above
the lowly creatures that crawled across
the sea floor
then came the plants also subdivided
into superior flowering plants
and inferior mushrooms and mosses
finally at the very bottom of the chain
came the minerals
which possessed none of the vitality of
life and yet still prove themselves of
value through their strength
and solidity this strict linear
classification is far removed from our
modern understanding of the living world
but nevertheless it was a world view
that persisted into the 19th century
it became the central canon for
pseudosciences like alchemy
since the linking of all matter in a
chain implied unity
and the theoretical possibility of
transmutation up that chain
to produce more kingly materials like
gold and diamond
early evolutionary scientists reasoned
that this transmutation was also
possible within living things
they believed that over time living
matter would transform
to become more advanced and move up the
great chain of being
this gave rise to the popular concept of
a missing link
[Music]
it may be theoretically possible for a
mere animal to become a man
but that link in the chain is hidden
from us
for now
[Music]
but there was a light at the end of the
tunnel for this seemingly unbreakable
chain of existence
[Music]
in the 18th century a swedish botanist
named carl linnaeus
proposed a new way of classifying life
he recognized the differences between
animals plants and minerals
but placed them in separate unrelated
groups
these groups he named kingdoms
ultimately creating similar unranked
subdivisions within them
they became classes orders genera and
species
every living thing therefore belonged in
a nested group of categories
that had no place for concepts of
biological superiority
thus for the first time humans could be
found within the kingdom of animals
the class of mammals and the order of
primates
their unique classification as humans
within the larger group of primates
is given by their binomial name
homo sapiens
[Music]
during this great age of scientific
discovery in the mid-1700s
carl linnaeus classified around 10 000
living things in this way
including six thousand plants and around
four thousand animals
[Music]
his meticulous organization laid the
foundation for all
modern biological classification and
binomial nomenclature has found its way
into common parlance
with the likes of tyrannosaurus rex and
escherichia coli
better known as the bacteria behind food
poisoning
e coli
today of course we have abandoned the
kingdom of minerals from biological
classification systems
three centuries of scientific discovery
have added other kingdoms alongside the
plant and animals
recognizing their fundamental and
irreconcilable differences
fungi and protists each earn their own
kingdom
and the inclusion of the prokaryotic
bacteria bring the total
to five
[Music]
but this isn't the full picture
just as the last three centuries or so
have brought new understanding of the
macroscopic world
so the last few decades have changed our
thinking on the micro cosmos too
the physical differences between
microscopic organisms may not be
immediately obvious
but as scientists probe even further
into their minute physiology and their
genetic makeup
even the simplest prokaryotes seem to be
remarkably diverse
of the one and a half million species
that have been formally described
prokaryotes make up less than one
percent
but scientists have good reason to
believe that there are many
many more still waiting to be discovered
[Music]
in 2012 about 1400 new bacterial species
previously unknown to science
were discovered living in the belly
buttons of university students
[Music]
the most recent estimates suggest that
the four other kingdoms of life
animals plants fungi and protists make
up just
20 per cent of all biodiversity
the rest numbering some one and a half
billion
species is all bacteria
[Music]
not only that but the divisions within
the prokaryotes are wider than we could
ever have imagined
although they may look similar to our
magnified eyes there are in fact
prokaryotes more distinct from one
another than bacteria
are from us
[Music]
in 1977 a pair of american
microbiologists
carl woes and george fox identified
fundamental differences in the genetic
structure of different types of simple
prokaryotes
these differences were so deep rooted
that they warranted not just a new
kingdom
but an entirely new level of
classification
this revelation changed the linear dogma
that had held sway
for 300 years
the exotic prokaryotes that had caused
such a stir became known as the archaea
and they define a domain of life
characterized by their distinctive
genetic makeup
archaean prokaryotes tend to live in
extreme environments
like hot springs intensely salty waters
and even inside petroleum deposits deep
underground
unlike their distant bacterial cousins
they never cause disease
with the recent discovery of the archaea
the new system of biological
classification recognizes
two other distinct domains
the true bacteria and the
nuclear-sparing eukaryotes
which include the animals plants fungi
and protist kingdoms
surprisingly when geneticists
reconstruct the tree of life
they find that we as members of the
eukaryotic domain are more closely
related to the extreme
archaea than we are to the bacteria that
live within our bodies
tracing our origins back in time
scientists believe that the eukaryotic
domain split from the archaea
around 2 billion years ago when the
endosymbiotic associations between
predatory prokaryotes and their
internally enslaved prey
became irreversible but the split
between bacterial
and archaeal branches is almost twice as
old
and may have occurred very soon after
the origin of life itself
and so we can picture the immense tree
of life
at 4 billion years old
[Music]
its colossal trunk meets the ground at a
single point
but soon diverges into two massive
branches
one representing the bacteria strikes
out for the sun
but the other splits in two again
these become the archaeal and eukaryotic
branches and each splits time and time
again
into dense crowns that represent not
only the huge diversity of life in
earth's modern biosphere
but every living being we know of that
has ever existed
[Music]
today homo sapiens as members of the
primate order
the mammalian class the vertebrate
phylum
the animal kingdom and the eukaryotic
domain
sit at the top of this elaborate and
incredibly complex tree
we may look down from the crown and
consider ourselves masters of all
but in reality we are merely a single
leaf sharing the sunlight
with billions of others all species
alive today can trace their heritage
down through the vast tree of life
to one of the three major branches and
then
to its root
ultimately we have the four billion year
long growth of this tree
to thank for our tenuous place
in the sun
you've been watching the entire history
of the earth don't forget to like and
subscribe
let us know what you think in the
comments and we'll see you
next time
you